today i've got a riddle for you how can
you prove to someone that you know a
secret without giving it away now this
is a pretty fun one so i want you to
pause the video now and really think
about it and then
let us know in the comments what you
think it's pretty rare for technologies
to be born from ambitious philosophical
concepts right or perhaps mind games but
when it comes to security and
cryptography everything is a riddle
good
let me try and we'll know for sure
so let's take a look at something known
as the zero knowledge proof technique
now as partly suggested by the name it
uses cryptographic algorithms to
basically allow several parties to
verify the authenticity of a piece of
information without actually giving that
piece of information away
but how is it possible to prove
something without the supporting
evidence well today i'm going to try my
best to break it down for you as easily
as possible my name is bradley peak and
this is some sub let's get into it
[Music]
we're asking ourselves day after day why
on earth would people want to use such a
complicated technique well the truth is
millions of people are using the
internet every day and they are
accepting cookies and sharing personal
information all in exchange for access
to services and digital products users
are gradually becoming more and more
vulnerable to security breaches and also
unauthorized access to their data and
furthermore individuals frequently have
to give up their privacy in return for
digital platform services such as
suggestions consultations tailored
support and so on all of which by the
way wouldn't be available when browsing
privately due to all the above mentioned
there is a certain asymmetry regarding
access to information you give your
information in exchange for service but
companies they rarely do the same
in 1985 three great minds goldwasser
mikali and rakhoff noticed a great
disturbance in the force ahead of their
time and they released a paper called
the knowledge complexity of interactive
proof systems now this actually
introduced the concept of zero knowledge
proof systems for the first time and it
was branded zkp right an early version
of their paper was released in 1982 and
was actually rejected three times from
major conferences
and the paper was rejected like six
seven times god knows
but we were very persistent you know
well zkp is a set of tools that allows
an item of data to be evaluated without
actually having to reveal the data that
supports it and this is made feasible by
a set of cryptographic methods that
allow a prover to mathematically prove
to a verifier that a computational
statement is valid without actually
disclosing any data at all now it is
possible this way to establish the
particular factor correct without
actually having to share
any of that data with a third party for
example a user could demonstrate that
say he or she is of legal age without
actually having to reveal their exact
age it's kind of like showing your
friend your driver's license to prove
you can drive instead of showing him
that you can drive via road tripping to
mexico right
okay
this technique is often used in the
digital world too and it's used to
authenticate systems without the risk of
information being stolen indeed it's no
longer necessary to provide any personal
data in order to establish a person's
identity cool right
so the notion that you can
have your cake i needed too
it can be done you can actually have
both correctness and privacy well now
i'm going to explain how this works but
before i do i need to say that we're
focusing on interactive zero knowledge
proofs just in case you get some
cybernet case in the comment section
saying oh but bradley zero knowledge
proofs can be non-interactive yes they
can mate but we're not looking at those
today so stay with me guys and keep your
thinking caps on so the prover and the
verifier are the two most important
roles in zero knowledge proofs the
prover must demonstrate that they are
aware of the secret whereas the verifier
must be able to determine whether or not
the approver is lying
[Music]
now this all works because the approver
asks the verifier to do actions that can
only be done if he or she is aware of
the secret if the proofer is guessing
the verifies tests will catch him or
higher out and if the secret is known
the approval will pass the verifiers
exam with flying colours every single
time it's similar to when a bank or
other institution requests letters from
a known secret word in order to
authenticate your identity we've all
seen that right i mean you're not
telling the bank how much money you have
in your account you're simply
demonstrating that you probably know
let's assume that there are two
characters alice and bob they find
themselves at the mouth of a cave with
two independent entrances leading to two
different paths a and b
now a door inside the cave connects both
parts but it can only be unlocked with a
secret code this code belongs to bob the
prover and alice the verifier wants to
buy it but first she wants to make sure
that bob isn't lying how can bob
demonstrate to alice that he has the
code without divulging its contents will
they perform the following to achieve
this bob enters the cave via one of the
entrances at random while alice waits
outside either a or b now once inside
alice approaches the front door summons
bob and instructs him to use one of the
two exits now in theory bob will always
be able to return via the path alice
directs him to even if it does not
coincide with the one that he chose in
the first place because he can unlock
the door in the middle and apart through
the other side with the secret code but
wait a minute there's still a chance 50
50 that alice and bob choose the same
path right well that's correct however
if this exercise is repeated several
times the likelihood that bob will
escape along the same path chosen by
alice without possessing the code
decreases every single time until it's
almost impossible conclusion well if bob
leaves the correct path a sufficient
number of times he's unmistakably shown
to alex that his claim of holding the
secret code is true moreover there's no
real need to reveal the code in this
case so you can find out more about the
bob and alice metaphor here so visit the
link after the video
as for right now zkp is developing hand
in hand with blockchain technology zcash
is a crypto platform that uses a unique
iteration of zero knowledge proofs
called zk snarks and allows native
transactions to stay entirely encrypted
while still being confirmed under the
network's consensus rules it's a great
example of this technology being used in
practice and this stuff really makes
crypto anonymous moreover this
technology can be used for what's called
anonymous verifiable voting establishing
explicit governance norms for disputed
ledger technologies has always been very
difficult and well anonymous and
verifiable voting is critical for
ensuring adequate on-chain governance
systems our democracies rely on
elections
every democracy from a shareholders
board meeting to the governmental system
in the united states requires voting and
as more countries move towards
digitalization and security tokens are
becoming more prevalent the demand for
secure and anonymous voting solutions is
only going to grow elections should be
verifiable
so zkps appear to be very promising and
useful in this case now this is due to
the way in which zkp's handle anonymous
and verifiable voting there's no longer
a requirement for that trusted third
party to validate the outcomes because
they're all recorded on a public
blockchain and furthermore any chance of
censorship is practically eliminated
eligible voters can now use zkp's to
establish their entirety devote without
actually revealing their identity
effectively making the voting system
anonymous and zkp's also give voters the
option of requesting verifiable proof
that their vote was actually counted in
the final tally really cool and even if
the votes themselves are not available
on say a public blockchain the electoral
authority can actually audit the vote
outcomes even though zero knowledge
proofs have a lot of potential to change
the way today's data systems verify
information the technology is still
considered to be in its infancy
primarily because researchers are still
figuring out how best they can use this
concept while identifying any potential
flaws for a deep dive into the technical
aspects of the concept consider watching
alberto cenino explaining this all on
the computer file channel now it's only
a short one today but i hope that we've
given you a bit of food for thought feel
free to rest assured that you've
survived another night in the online
jungle unscathed and i shall see you my
ibir nitawareshi in the next video so
thanks for watching
[Music]